the person who's been banned gets a
bigger presence because all of those
people they've inspired or all those
people that have been drawn to them now
feel like they're under attack and say
okay we've got a band together and we're
going to just get his content out more
and more because they can't ban
everybody yeah so is that what you think
is going to happen with tate yeah i
think he's going to become more powerful
he's going to have to use a different
strategy but it's going to draw more
kids to him and the thing is what people
don't understand is the best part about
open communication is it allows you to
go against dogma it allows if somebody
says something stupid i can make a
counterpoint to prove that they're that
person's stupid most people can
see that that's stupid and they're gonna
judge based on what they believe is
right when you silence people
you you give them more like you said you
give them more power and not only that
when you try to make certain
conversations taboo
only people of both sides of the
extremes are going to have that
conversation now